thank you
so much for talking to me today uh top
gun is one of my favorite films
uh and you know it's endured it's had
fans forever and you know i'm curious
from your perspective kind of looking
back
at the time it was a bit of a risky
endeavor you know it was tony scott's
second movie
tom was just starting to break out i
know the production itself was
complicated given
you know all the fighter pilot scenes
and the navy's involvement
when did you know you know that it was
working or did you have an inkling that
it was going to be special as as you
were making it
well you don't really know the audience
usually tells you
at least for me a lot of people say they
have a hit movie before it comes out
i never know i don't think they know
either but all you know is you
you put all your energy your time and
your creativity into making something
and you hope that audiences will embrace
it very very fortunate that they embrace
top gun
in fact we have the new version coming
out
just with color and sound it's going to
be in 130 some theater 150 theaters
dovely theaters
amc uh for one week on may
13th which is top gun day it's also
a hugely influential film i mean tony's
got really solidified
you know his unique visual aesthetic and
style on that movie
which really stood in contrast to how a
lot of films in the 80s looked at the
time so i was just curious what that
experience was like for you as a
producer
you know were there any points of
contention or were you eager to kind of
push that further into
visceral territory well we you know we
always had to hold tony back because he
was a real daredevil just like
yeah everything was safe and that was
that was a a
quest with tony because you know at one
point easter he
drove a motorcycle like a ninja and we
won
that nothing happened to him while we
were filming so we chained up his ninja
so he couldn't get
take off in it you know what cut the
locks off and took off anyway
that's funny in terms of the aesthetics
specifically was there any nervousness
from
you know the studio at the time i mean
it was pretty radical what he was doing
well you know what happened is there was
a change in management the previous
management
wasn't really excited about top gun ned
tannen came into the studio and
tony and i and don went up to ned's
house and he said ned told us he said i
really don't have much to make
tell me what this story is and tony just
got off a plane with london
london he was tired and he kind of froze
couldn't say a word
and don who was a great salesman you
know and a pitch man got up and told the
whole story a
top gun danced around the room and and
you know the the tom cruise kind of arc
the maverick arc in the movie
and ned said to me how much do you think
it's going to cost and i said i think
around
14 and then turned us into tony said go
make the movie
those were the old days that doesn't
happen now you go through
stuff to get a movie made not at all
um the you know the you've lost that
love and feeling scene
was instantly iconic you know it is
endured for
you know these past 35 years what do you
remember about putting that sequence
together and did you guys have an
inkling of how memorable it would end up
being well
that was warren scaring warren scarum
was one of the records he worked on i'm
not sure he's even credited
uh in fact the studio wouldn't even pay
for him dynamite pay for him
uh to to to work on the script and he
came up with that idea you've lost that
loving feeling
and the actors love it they love
performing and tom had a blast with it
so does the whole cast
it's one of my favorite scenes in the
entire film um and i've revisited the
movie a lot over the years and i think
one of the things that i keep coming
back to
uh and that's really helped it endure is
that it really is kind of a love story
between maverick and goose
um you know that relation to that
central relationship in the film
and when goose dies it it feels like
maverick has lost a partner
i was wondering if that kind of sense of
companionship uh
was discussed much as you guys were
putting that together well
that was an important central arc of of
the story and also
the the love story with kellen mcgillis
so those were the two pillars
of the movie and the third pillar was
was the action and
radiation especially in terms of how
that relationship
you know was put together what what were
kind of the discussions of laying that
bear because
you know goose's death is really
surprising in the film and it and it's
really devastating you really feel that
loss well i think we wanted to take the
audience through the experience that
maverick goes through when he loses his
best friend so we take the audience way
down and then
we start to build maverick back up so we
can get back in that
f-14 and carry on the last mission you
know
the chore that we had to get the
audience back from that
that terrible accident i mean obviously
this movie catapulted tom
and his career uh what was it like
working with him
at that time you know he's a very
curious actor he
asks a lot of questions he's all over
everything in a good way he wants to
know what everybody's doing
he's somebody who really enjoys making
movies he loves it he loves the script
process and he was included even though
he was a young actor at the time he was
working on the script with us he was
part of everything in making that film
and he's the best producer now that i've
ever
known or worked with so he's he's gone
to school
on all the great directors and producers
uh that work with them
along the way has he sent you a thank
you card for your work together
actually he did he made top gun maverick
that's the thank you card
i can't wait for that film um i'm also
curious about your continued
relationship with tony and tom on
days of thunder and how that experience
may be compared and contrasted to top
gun
well it was tom came to us and he said i
want to make this we can never get the
script right
and you know we brought tony in and we
had i think i think warren scaring
worked on that no i think
these that was robert town robert town
and and
he's he's got a great voice he's a
fantastic writer and he
he really got them the character that
tom wanted to play
cole trickle and and he delivered it for
us and for tony
you've been involved with you know so
many great films
and franchises over the years and here
we are talking about top gun
35 years after it was first released
uh how does that rank among films when
you know people or filmmakers want to
ask you about
is it kind of towards the top there it's
always the
on the top of the list the top gun is
became such an iconic movie that we're
celebrating 35 years later
it's coming back in theaters in 150 amc
theaters on may 13th so how many movies
get re-released after 35 years
yeah quite unbelievable it also visually
holds up
so well um you know we've been through
this whole visual effects spectacle
and you know the cg driven blockbusters
that dominate the marketplace and
i think you know nothing really beats
the visceral thrills of this movie what
what do you attribute that to 100 tony
scott and tony scott just designed it
did all the storyboards himself he'd get
up at four in the morning do a
storyboard be on the set
you know at seven get home at one or two
in the morning and get up at four i
don't know
he never slept he was unbelievable he
worked so hard
to make this movie the iconic movie it
has become
and you know we're inclusive when we
make films we
encourage the actors to work with us and
of course tony and the writers
and the cinematographer we bring
everybody in and to be part of the
family to make
really interesting iconic movies you
know the the film's legacy has endured
its popularity is endured
uh it's it's kept reaching generations
since it's gone on
um and it's just curious this may be a
bit of a generic question but
for you having been there from the
beginning do you have any idea why this
movie connected so well is
is there any kind of like quantifiable
uh quality that you attribute
that to i think it's a combination of
the artistry of tony
the trick the screenwriter and then tom
brought it home tom did it
he became the iconic actor he was
already a rising star
and this one made him a worldwide star
he told me stories where he was i think
he was in africa or scouting for some
another picture he was working on a
little kid runs up to him and
kind of pulls on his coat and says
maverick maverick this is a place that
had no telephones
i mean it's it's it's quite amazing what
what a movie can do to capture an
audience around the world and
and put out our values and the kind of
great filmmaking and filmmakers that we
have well thank you so much for
taking the time to talk to me today
thank you for top gun and all of your
films and best of luck with top gun
maverick
thanks adam i really appreciate your
time